الاتفاق النووي عام 2015 سمح لايران
باستخدام الجيد الجيل الاول فقط من اجهزه
الطرد المركزي اي ار واحد لكن منذ خروج
الولايات المتحده من الاتفاق عام 2018
قامت طهران بتركيبه مجموعات من اجهزه
الطرد المركزي اكثر كفاءه فجهاز ار اي
واحد يعتبر اول جيل من اجهزه الطرد
المركزيه التي انتجتها ايران عام 2001
وتمتلك حاليا
16000 منها في منشاتها النوويه وفي عام
2006 انتج طهران اول جهاز طرد مركزي متطور
باسم اي ار اثنان ام انتجت منه 1,000
وشهد عام 2008 انتاج ثلاثه اجهزه طرد
مركزي من نوع اي ار اربعه لاستخدامها في
البحوثقا في عام 2013 تم انتاج جهاز اي ار
5 للطرد المركزي وتم تركيبه 10 منه في
المنشات الايرانيه واختبارات طهران 2013
اجهزه اي ار 6 التي بدات بانتاجها عام
2009 اما اجهزته اي ار تسعه والتي تعتبر
احدث اجهزه طرد مركزيا ايراني وتم انتاجها
عام 2019